ah there I've decided to do a video blog
I guess it's called in response to
someone called our Noah page for
president he has commented quite a few
times on my youtubes and he says can you
do a V log about the silent period so
I'll do that and I'll talk about what I
call passive learning the silent period
take my glasses off I don't really have
to read anything know one thing I wanted
to mention there was another person who
said I've been practicing Russian for
almost half a year palletization is a
tricky thing to do I deal with that
quickly and then I'll get to the
question of the silent period and and
massive learning palletization I haven't
a clue what palletization is I've been
learning Russian on my own I listen I
repeat I try to get the sounds I don't
know what palletization is I think the
more we create special terms for
different things in the language in the
different languages the more we confuse
the learner I have no interest in
knowing what palletization is it's not a
problem
passive learning and the silent period I
believe that the language learning is an
intensely personal task it's you the
learner and the language the teacher is
a resource if you want the teacher but
fundamentally it's between you and the
language you have to like the language
you have to look for content it's easier
now because of the tremendous number of
podcasts and blogs and other resources
that are available on the Internet you
have to discover the language you have
to pick up on the rhythm of the language
you have to learn the words in the
language all of these things are you in
the language it's quite a draining thing
it's very enjoyable but it's it's very
exhausting because it grabs you takes
hold of you and and you're transforming
yourself to you're adding another layer
during your personality and the longest
the first long period of that is is you
doing it with the language in a
hardly passive way you're reading you're
listening you're listening over and over
again you may be repeating I think
repeating out loud is a good thing to do
that's helping you catch the rhythm of
the language you're listening sometimes
to the language spoken slowly sometimes
to the language spoken more quickly for
long periods of time content that you
are listening to is not very clear like
it's it's you can't really pick out
where the words begin and end sometimes
you know the words but you can't make
out the whole meaning you just have a
vague sense of the meaning and gradually
everything starts to fall into place and
that process can take you six months to
a year I mean it can take four long run
even longer because there will always be
aspects of the language situations
movies conversations would be for
whatever that you continue not to
understand but the amount the the area
of the language that you're able to
understand that this starts to become
clear to you and natural to you gets
larger and larger and so you get a
natural feeling for the language and
your vocabulary increases and during
that period of getting acquainted with
the language I don't personally feel any
urgency to speak I have not sought out
people with whom to speak Russian which
is the language that I've been learning
recently obviously if I stumble on
someone who is a Russian speaker I will
try out my Russian it's fun I was even
in a situation in Holland after I had
only been listening to Russian about six
months for a blind Russian person in
this Dutch hotel was not being properly
looked after it was obviously in a state
of anxiety and I even with my limited
Russian was able to help him and make
him feel comfortable and tell him what
time he was supposed to get the bus and
so forth is the hotel staff were too
busy look after him properly and so I
was very satisfied I was able to use the
Russian
learn but I have no great urgency to
speak it and I'm not losing anything in
my opinion that's not to say that it
isn't a good thing I'm just going to
occasionally watch my time here I'm not
saying that it's not where is my time on
this thing anyways obviously it's a good
thing to speak whether it's a good thing
to speak speaking does a number of
things for you it forces you to try to
remember the things that you have been
learning passively and I think that
helps to prime the pump and then makes
you you know better able to remember
things it makes you conscious of where
your gaps are it makes you conscious of
things that you can't say words that you
don't have so that you start to look for
those in your listening and reading it's
a challenge so to the extent that you
meet the challenge it's satisfying to
the extent that you don't need the
challenge it can be sometimes a bit
discouraging sometimes it's a little bit
stressful it's a fun thing to do you
don't need a lot of it in my opinion if
after maybe a month or two of dedicated
listening a lot of listening to
repetitive listening to simple content
and you gradually start to move on to
more difficult content you have a bit of
vocabulary then you might want to speak
once a week that's enough if you're
fortunate enough to be in the country
where the language is spoken or you have
a friend then and if you have access to
more opportunities be fine go for it but
it's not crucial to me you need that
first period to build up the vocabulary
the familiar familiarity with the
language you know I often de-emphasize
grammar but obviously you've got to get
some sense of how the language works
initially by observation and there's
nothing wrong
being a small grammar book where you you
know just have a quick summary of it
don't try to remember any of the
explanations but just to get some sense
like okay learning Russian that you know
the past ends in an L and that the
feminine past tense is an L a so they
actually have a feminine form of the
past tense determined by the speaker so
you know these are a few little things
like that that when you get into the
more complex explanations the
conditionals the modal's the
subjunctives the the perfective verbs
and Russian all this kind of stuff
through the explanations for the
different cases is over this is no way
so let's get some sense of how the
language works and then start to observe
the language listen to the language like
the language you get the rhythm like the
music expand your vocabulary this can be
six to six months to a year or longer I
mean I have been a sense I have been
doing it for two years because I have no
real need to speak Russian I very much
enjoy my reading now that I'm reading
Russian history and reading Russian
literature of the 19th century I'm
listening to audiobooks of the same
material that's what I like to do I'm
happy doing what I'm doing with the
language I am meeting my objectives in
the language and at the same time I'm
I'm building myself up so that should I
go to Russia or you know not so long ago
I went to an evening of Russian theater
here in Vancouver and there was a lady
sitting beside me in order lady got to
be careful who I call older because I'm
not that young myself but I was able to
carry on a conversation with her in
Russian we talked about the play and we
talked about different things and that
that was a great source of satisfaction
so if it's there yes but I don't go out
looking for it and I think that we can
do a lot of good to ourselves if we
focus on this passive learning no
teacher correcting you no need to
perform no need to feel inadequate
nothing wrong with passive vocabulary it
hasn't yet converted itself into active
vocabulary so what I take great
satisfaction
in the fact that I've accumulated enough
vocabulary so that I can read you know
serious books good enough so and a dump
and this is the other thing I don't got
it careful it's got to be under ten
minutes here but all this business about
helping you read reading strategies pre
reading post reading I mean I got this
Russian textbook and they had all kinds
of like twelve or fifteen different
things to do before and after you read
no just read and listen enjoy it and
Reuben Alba's really stresses this and
he says somewhere he says there is
nothing as incompatible with the
enjoyment of reading as much as this
whole business of analyzing and
interpreting and and explaining what you
have just read the important thing is to
enjoy the music of a language to enjoy
the sounds of the language to enjoy the
the the wonders of literature
communicating with a person of a
different century of a different country
country a different culture in his
language and to get to that stage of
scriptures you can so silent period six
months one year eighteen months
depending on your circumstances it's a
great way to learn you shouldn't feel
under any obligation to speak and
therefore be wary of going to courses
where they force you to speak and thank
you goodbye for now